are you afraid of dying at all yes but I
will say that I've got a lot better I
mean I used to really be scared of it
I'd definitely hit the next level of
like oh I'm grateful that I got this
much and including my parents and
including other people I love my cousin
cousin Bobby or Brandon my best friend
you know what I mean you know my dad
lost his dad at 15. my mom lost her mom
in five six
devastating that was like a cloud in my
life you know why am I driven by
gratitude as a kid because my parents
lost a parent at 5 and 15. it hung on me
and then I myself I'm older now than
when my dad's dad died and when my mom's
mom died you know what I mean yeah so
death has been a thing that I thought
about a lot and so yes I I do fear it
and I fear it right now I wouldn't want
to go now too much to do too many of you
to flip your perspective right before I
get the [__] out of here